I've heard it called
a death letter.
Yeah,
but I don't know if
that is the actual name.
I don't know if it has an actual name,
but I do know what it is.
It is something that soldiers sometimes,
right when they deploy into harms way.
Okay.
Then they put it with your gear or in
a foot locker where it will be found or
they give it to a friend to pass on
in case they die.
Okay.
A letter to the family.
They won't see you again.
Okay.
To mothers that gave them life
to fathers that raised them
to wives
that they left at home
to children they miss and in
some cases to the children
they've never even met.
Okay.
It's a good by letter
with the title.
Something like in case I don't come home.
Well,
Jesse givens
of Springfield, Missouri
wrote one of those letters.
He wrote it to his wife
Melissa and their son, Dakota
nickname toad
and to their unborn son,
nickname bean,
who would ultimately be named Carson.
And here is what he said
in that letter
in case he didn't come home.
My family.
I never thought I would be
writing a letter like this.
I really don't know where to start.
I've been getting bad
feelings though and well,
if you're reading this,
I am forever in to you,
Dakota and the bean.
I searched all my life for a
dream and I found it in you.
Okay?
I would like to think that I made a
positive difference in your lives.
I will never be able
to make up for the bad.
I am so sorry.
The happiest moments in my life
all deal with my little family.
I will always have with me the
small moments we all shared.
Yeah.
The moments when you quit taking
life so seriously and smiled.
The sounds of a beautiful boys laughter
or the simple nudge of a baby unborn.
You will never know how complete you
have made me each and every one of you.
You saved me from loneliness and
taught me how to think beyond myself.
You taught me how to live and to love.
You opened my eyes to a world
I never dreamed existed.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm proud of you.
Stay on the path you choose.
Never lose sight of what is important.
You and our babies,
Dakota,
you are more sun than
I could ever ask for.
I can only hope I was half the dad.
I used to be your Danny,
but no matter what,
it makes me proud that you chose me.
You taught me how to care until it hurts.
You've taught me how to smile again.
Yeah,
you taught me that life isn't so
serious and sometimes you have to play.
You have a big beautiful heart
through life.
You need to keep it open and follow it.
Never be afraid to be yourself.
I will always be there in our park
when you dream so we can still play.
I hope someday you will
have a son like mine.
Make them smile and shine just like you.
Okay.
I love you towed and I hope someday you
will understand why I didn't come home.
Please be proud of me.
Please don't stop loving life.
Yeah,
take in every breath like it's your first.
Yeah.
I love you towed.
I will always be there with you.
I'll be in the sun shadows,
dreams and joys of your life.
Okay,
baby.
Been,
yeah,
I never got to see you,
but I know in my heart you are beautiful.
I know you will be strong and big
hearted just like your mom and brother.
I will always have with me the fuel of
the soft nudge is on your mom's belly and
the joy I felt when we found
out you were on your way.
Yeah.
Hi, dream of you every
night. I always will.
Don't ever think that since I wasn't
around that I didn't love you.
Okay.
You were conceived of love and I
came to this terrible place for love.
I love you as I do your mom and
brother with all my heart and soul.
Please understand that I had to be gone
so that I could take care of my family.
I love you being,
I have never been so blessed
as the day I met Melissa.
Okay.
You are my angel, Soul Mate, wife, lover,
and best friend.
I am sorry.
I did not want to have
to write this letter.
Okay.
There is so much more I
need to say so much more.
I need to share a lifetime's worth.
I married you for a million lifetimes.
Yeah,
that's how long I will be with you.
Please keep our babies safe.
Please find it in your heart to
forgive me for leaving you alone.
Take care of yourself. Believe
in yourself. You are a strong,
big hearted woman.
Teach our babies to live life to its
fullest and tell yourself to do the same.
Don't forget to take PTO to Disneyworld.
I'll be there with you.
Melissa,
I will always want you,
need you and love you in my heart,
mind and soul.
Do me a favor.
After you talk towed in Benin,
give them hugs and kisses from me.
Go outside,
look at the stars and count them.
Don't forget to smile.
Love always your husband,
Jess
and Jessie
didn't come home
on May.
First 2003 Jesse givens was killed while
conducting combat operations in Hominy,
Iraq.
When is Abrams tank plunged
into the Euphrates river?
After the bank along the river collapsed,
the three other crew members
made it out of the tank.
Jesse did not.
Oh,
another
brave warrior
garden
like so many other warriors.
He left behind a family,
a wife,
and children,
and the mother and father
and friends and life
you have behind everything.
Every smile, every laugh,
every hug from his boys,
every kiss from his wife,
everything.
Go ahead.
And on this Memorial Day,
let us remember.
Let us remember those soldiers,
sailors,
airmen,
and marines,
those brave warriors who for us,
for our freedom,
left everything behind.
And after the sun sets
on this memorial day
and darkness consumes the sky,
go outside.
Yeah.
And look up,
okay.
And say thank you
to those heroes that
now grace the heavens.
Okay.
And then look at the stars.
Count them.
And as much as your soul
aches with sadness as you,
more your fallen family
and friends
and brothers and arms,
don't forget that they did not sacrifice
their lives for us to live in sadness.
No.
Okay.
They sacrificed their lives so we
could leave in joy and happiness.
So
even on this most solemn day,
Memorial Day,
don't forget
for them
to smile.